hi everyone this is just a quick video
to let everybody know that I've started
an alternate channel called the null
globe it's not weight-related I know it
looks like it but it's not which for all
you non Rick and Marty phones right
there that's the volgin backwards I'm
doing this because I want the volgen to
stay completely SCP related and my
second channel will be everything else
so if you're interested in my voice
acting in general this is not SCP
related I may put joke SCPs on that I
don't know let me know what you think
anyway about the Jocassee pace I noticed
on my last video the SCP 49 j video that
I uploaded yesterday there was slightly
more dislikes than usual it's not there
isn't loads or anything just not as many
dislikes as normal SCP things get so
yeah if you go over to that channel it's
gonna be non SCP related mostly comedy
copypasta green tax reads and other
experimental stuff the main focus is
gonna be comedy but I'm a nine cent at
nine I'm not gonna be posting on it
straightaway but if you want to
subscribe to you at nine you'll be
notified of whenever I do that kind of
thing I know not a lot of people will be
interested in this because you know
predominantly my fan base lessons to me
for SCP and that's fine but that's 100
percent fine I'm just trying to organize
it better so the people that come for
SCP will get SCP and not be confused
there was a few things that I read a
couple years ago like the Navy SEAL
copypasta that has a lot of you know but
people that seem that that are you
unsubscribed to my channel were probably
really disappointed because they were
expecting that kind of content which I
don't really do that often so I hope you
understand why I'm moving all that to
another channel I can't see any
downsides to it really but okay wow I've
rambled on a lot
thanks very much for listening and I
will be posting Grayson thank you very
much and good bye